this is such a beautiful thing because
it shows how much more valuable memes
are and rational arguments
you're right
all right but feelings are way more than
your facts it's it's just way better in
actually winning a culture War scenario
because here's the beautiful thing about
this Bud Light is Anna Harris bush is in
this hellacious position because they
because due to the corporate pressure
because they have to please all the
progressives they know they can't back
down
but they also know that they've lost the
culture War here they know that they've
now been graded this status that is an
insult to the average American and so
now they're trapped in this hard place
where any attempt to recover their image
will burn them with their corporate
Bettors with Wall Street with the
investment class but anything that they
do you know to try to recover that image
is just going to Doom them but they also
are just going to continue to Hemorrhage
money if they don't do something and
this exemplifies perfectly what you were
saying earlier about the fact that the
elite have an entirely different set of
morals that they want to push out of the
General Public